إن كونك محبوسًا في المنزل وبعيدًا عن
صالة الألعاب الرياضية
أو استوديو اليوجا يمكن أن يجعل من
الصعب متابعة
صحتنا هذه الأيام ، لكن
خبيرة الصحة واللياقة البدنية ستيفاني منصور تقول إنه
يمكنك ببساطة اللجوء إلى هاتفك للتحقق
من هذه
التطبيقات المحمولة الستة التي تقولها  يمكن أن يساعدك في الحفاظ على
خضوعك للمساءلة ، يعد تعقب العادات أمرًا رائعًا لأي
عادة تتطلع إلى تنميتها ، مثل
الكتابة في مجلة الامتنان
أو ممارسة اليوجا ، لا يتطلب الاستيقاظ حتى
حصيرة يمكنك
الاستيقاظ على روتين اليوجا والتأمل
أثناء وجودك في السرير ، يساعدك شرب المزيد من الماء على
حبس الماء طوال اليوم ، فإن
شرب المزيد من الماء سيساعد في
مكافحة التعب ويقلل
الصداع ويساعد في تسريع عملية التمثيل الغذائي
للمساعدة في إنقاص الوزن.
حرفيًا ، تفقد البرد ،
إنه تطبيق يساعدك على تتبع الطعام
ويمنحك القليل من التذكيرات حول
ما تحتاج إلى تحسينه أو
الأطعمة الشائعة
في دفتر يومياتك اليومية.
لا تتبع فقط الطعام ولكن أيضًا
اللياقة البدنية ، يمكنك الوصول إلى إجراءات اللياقة
البدنية وأيضًا الوصفات وتتبع نجاحك في إنقاص الوزن
جميعًا على هواتفنا ، فلماذا لا
تجعل هاتفك
يعمل من أجلك وتنزيل بعض
تطبيقات الصحة واللياقة البدنية
لساعة المستهلك اليوم i
ماندي يعطيك